okay so I'm going to begin with an
example uh so this is a very simple
model uh it says that the amount of
wheat grown in a field depends on the
amount of rainfall and the Acres of
wheat
planted in this model rainfall and
acreage are exogenous variables so for
example wheat growth depends on rainfall
but rainfall does not depend on wheat
growth and if you've done anything in
the social sciences you might know that
typically finding an exogenous variable
is a total nightmare you think
something's exogenous but it's not but
this is about as uncontroversial an
example of an exogenous variable you're
ever going to
find but it turns out that if we think
of these not as just single events but
as things that we're measuring
repeatedly so rainfall year after year
wheat growth year after
year and if we think about a long enough
time
scale it could be that over a 100 years
200 years agriculture does influence
climate at that time scale any influence
of wheat growth on rainfall is so slow
and so small that we can just ignore
it okay so that's just the starting
example and I'm using it as a way to
illustrate the notion of the time scale
relativity of causal
representations and that's something
I'll be talking a lot
about
now in addition to illustrating that
concept uh hopefully this will start to
illustrate the broader theme of The Talk
which is that the relationship between
time and causation and causal models is
a lot more intricate than you might have
thought so as I'll talk about uh when
we're talking about graphical causal
inference methods uh so people like
Pearl spir spirit is more shinness yeah
uh yeah Janan was mentioning them uh
that these method me do not typically
infer causal order from time ordering so
that causes precede their effects plays
surprisingly little role in these
methods uh but when we look at what's
going on many of the assumptions are
really assumptions about temporal
stability uh and stable behaviors
arising at particular spatial temporal
scales uh and the point of today's talk
is to show how to use Dynamic OA models
uh as developed by iwazaki and Simon in
order to better understand these time
scale and stability
assumptions okay so let me start saying
a bit more about the relationship
between causation and time in causal
models
what yeah so the reference is uh In
Search of Lost Time
ordering shouldn't be competing with PR
probably bad idea
but yeah so graphical causal inference
methods do not build time order into
their causal semantics uh so for
instance if we have these two hypotheses
X causes y causes Z or x and z are
causes of Y uh in standard
constraint-based methods we do not
distinguish between these hypotheses by
saying that if the first is true then y
comes before Z and if the second is true
Z comes before y but rather in terms of
the probabilistic implications so if the
first is true then x and z are
independent probab istically conditional
and Y if the second is true x and z are
independent but dependent conditional
and
Y so that is the
standard implications of these models uh
of course people will St to say that
among observationally equivalent models
uh that you can then use time but it
plays often a very secondary
role and in some ways I think that this
is a really good thing um for reason
going reasons going a bit back to Tomas
talk because on the one hand I think
it's really philosophically useful to
distinguish between time ordering and
causal ordering for example even if you
think that causes always perceive their
effects in time you might want to know
why is that the case and if you think
that it's just part of the definition of
causation that causes come before their
effects then you can't even ask that
question so I think the fact that using
causal models you can understand the
probabilistic implications of the caus a
symmetry without referring to time is
huge conceptual Improvement but that
being said it's still a bit puzzling how
small a role time plays in these models
and you might actually just wonder well
okay like how do we actually understand
the temporal relations among these
variables and I don't think it's always
totally
clear so for example when I give talks
to audiences and I present directed as
cyclic graphs so they do not allow
cycles and then someone will ask oh is
that a problem that you don't allow
Cycles in these these graphs and then if
I feel just like giving the standard
answer I'll say no no no it's not a
problem at all because even in cases
where we have apparent Cycles you can
just time index the variables so you
think there's a cycle between income and
education because people with more
income can get more education and vice
versa but we just need to talk about
income at time T equals z causing
education at time T equals 1 and so on
and so
forth and thing to notice about this
response is it just presupposes that
when we're given a causal graph and we
haven't mentioned the time relations
among the variables they really do have
time relations we just haven't said what
they are and we just time index
them and I don't think that's the only
option so again the time indexing option
the idea is just well these variables
just implicitly are time index they're
what philosophers or metaphysicians
would call events we just forgot to
mention when they happened uh even
though as Samantha pointed out that
would be really really useful to know
what I suggest in instead is that often
what's going on isn't that we're just
considering variables that have times we
haven't mentioned them but rather we're
considering variables that in some sense
abstract away from the temporal
relations among the measured
variables so here's to give just some
sense of what I mean by that imagine we
have some Vector variables could for
example be a Time series well depending
what assumptions we make we might be
able to represent this Vector of
measured variables as a single variable
for the data generating process uh so
for example if we have a stationary time
series uh then time order doesn't matter
so we might not need to keep track of
which variables come before others in
the ordering uh I mean to think of a
really simple case if all of them were
generated by some variable which was a
mean plus a Time stationary error term
then you could just have a single
variable for the data generating process
even though you can measure it at
different times because time isn't
making a difference uh in the event you
have non-stationarity it becomes more
complicated uh and my point here isn't
that you can't do causal inference with
non-stationary time series just to
becomes more complicated uh and in
general I I I'm just restraining myself
I'd love to talk a lot more about time
series and if anyone does want to talk
about it either in the Q&A or after the
talk very glad to but the point here is
just to give you a sense
about what I'm suggesting when I'm
suggesting that we have a model where
we've just represented some variable
like pressure or temperature or height
or whatever it doesn't matter and we
haven't mentioned the time and it's
because in some sense we've made some
temporal assumption that allows us to
abstract away from the temporal
relations among the measured variables
and stationarity could be one such
assumption now bro more broadly I think
that there's a historical reason for why
it is that time is omitted from causal
models in this way and I think it has to
do with the develop ment of causal
models as part of econometrics and as
part of the structural equation
tradition uh and at least historically
the earliest applications of these
tended to be to systems at equilibrium
or with relatively stable time
stationary
Dynamics uh and I think that history of
the development of causal models as part
of this tradition still influences
it now if you accept this story I
haven't really given you um
much evidence for it uh but I'm going to
put it on the table as a story we might
uh think about then the dynamic causal
models that I'm going to talk about are
going to be a generalization of standard
causal models because while standard
causal models consider system at
equilibrium or steady state Dynamic
causal models generalize to consider the
behaviors of the system away from
equilibrium uh and the upshot of this
philosophically is that even though I'll
be talking about in the next few slides
is about the relationship between
equilibrium and dynamic models and that
might seem really really obscure like
okay maybe some weird causal modelers
care about it but a serious philosophers
or metaphysicians don't uh I'm
suggesting that even when people do not
explicitly talk about equilibrium and
Dynamics the types of assumptions I'm
considering are often embedded in the
models and not made
explicit okay and the last part I'm just
going to um yeah I'll skip because I'll
come back to that okay and then last
preliminary so I'm talking about time
scale uh and one way we can understand
it's operationally so we're sampling
some quantity repeatedly and we can
think
about considering the system at a longer
time scale is sampling at a slower rate
uh to consider it at a shorter time
scale it's sample it more frequently and
when I talk about considering a systemat
equilibrium I'm imagining that we're
considering at time scale at which all
the variable have steady steady state by
the time they're sampled uh and to be
totally clear we could talk about
equilibrium and Dynamics without ever
explicitly talking about time scale but
it's helpful in cases where we want to
model a system as having a steady
long-term equilibrium we're tending
towards a steady long-term equilibrium
and then modeling transient Dynamics as
perturbations from the equilibrium
there's going to be a relationship
between the equilibrium Dynamic and
longer shorter time scale
distinction Okay so the next part of the
talk I'm going to now just give you the
basics of dynamic causal models and I'm
going to go all the way back to Herbert
Simon 1953 uh causal ordering and
identifiability uh and if you get
nothing else from this talk we should
all be reading a lot more Herbert Simon
that that's just one of the takeaways
it's never heard
anyone okay so Simon's wondering at
least in my
retelling where does the causal
asymmetry come from given that many of
the basic equations of Sciences have no
built-in asymmetry so paradigmatically
here we have the ideal gas law relating
the pressure volume and temperature of a
gas at equilibrium uh this is just an
equation that's just an ordinary equal
sign uh so this doesn't tell us whether
pressure causes temperature temperature
causes
pressure so where do the causal
asymmetry come from well Simon says uh
even if we don't get causal Direction
from this equation alone if we add
additional facts about the system we do
so if for
example there we go we say that it's in
a heat bath maintained at a constant
temperature uh and for example that's a
fixed volume system well now we get the
temperature and volume are exogenous and
from the values of those variables that
are exogenously set we can determine the
value of pressure and the basic idea
behind causal ordering is that the
causal ordering what causes what but
corresponds to the order in which we
solve for the the values of variables in
the equations uh and just to be really
clear here there's no magic here this is
not telling us how to get causal
conclusions without causal assumptions
so to say that temperature is exogenous
that's a causal assumption uh but it's
just making a bit more explicit where we
get this directionality from um and of
course we could have a different setup
so it could be the case that it's a
movable piston so now volume is not
fixed but equilibrium pressure is
and now we're going to get a different
set of causal
relations uh importantly when you can do
this solving for the causal ordering
well then you can rewrite the equations
as ordinary structural equations uh so
the type of stuff that we all know and
love uh you can give them a causal
interventionist interpretation you can
add error terms and they automatically
satisfy causal Markov uh so from this
basic framework you can get all the
stuff that everyone's more familiar with
but with an earlier starting
point okay and why this matters for us
really asked to do this later paper with
Yumi aisaki uh where they claim that the
initial causal ordering method was
initially defined only for static
systems consisting of equilibrium
equations uh now Simon had never really
explicitly said this uh but certainly
you can see that in the example I talked
about uh we're considering all these
equations at
equilibrium uh also uh historically
Simon was uh dealing often with the
simultaneous equation tradition from
econometrics uh and you might wonder
well how can you have simultaneous
equations if causations not
simultaneous and the way I suggest we
think about them is not that there has
to be simultaneous causation just that
we're considering the system at a time
scale at which the variables have had
sufficient time to respond to any
perturbations and reach steady
state okay so now next few slides this
is the technical part of the talk uh and
here I really just want to show you how
these models work and the basic
operations
involved okay so we just saw an
equilibrium representation or in fact
two equilibrium representations for the
you know two different ideal gas systems
uh here I'm just throwing at you a
dynamic CA model I'm going to unpack
this a bit uh so basically we're now
considering a model where we're not
assuming uh that volume has had time to
reach equilibri
so we're starting by thinking about a
movable piston system here we have a
mass on top of the Piston uh which is um
there's then a force on top of the
Piston which along with a force in the
bottom of the Piston uh influences the
acceleration of volume uh now these
dotted lines these are integration links
uh and integration links reflect the
fact that if you know a higher order
derivative of a variable uh then and you
know its current value uh then you can
derive its uh value at the next time
step through integration uh so this is
just you know integration in the sense
of the inverse of
differentiation so these dotted lines
the integration lengths they're going to
bring time into the causal model and one
thing that's kind of subtle here is that
because you need to specify initial
conditions in order to apply
integration the initial values of
variables that are away from equilibrium
are going to be exogenous so the dynamic
causal models will tell us how a system
evolves from initial conditions but
you're going to need to specify the
initial conditions and this is going to
be different than just an equilibrium
causal
model so yeah and we include time
derivatives and integration links only
for the variables that are considered to
be away from
equilibrium okay so in any case we have
now volume not in equilibrium volume and
temperature cause pressure which
influences the porce in the bottom and
just to see how the equation approach
works it works in basically the same way
as the original causal ordering method
uh except we have some more exogenous
variables because first of all we've
added mass and also the initial
conditions are
exogenous uh and then we solve for the
equations in the same way uh so Mass
determines the force in the
top um and the ideal gas law gives us
pressure from volume and temperature and
then
the force in the bottom is proportional
to the pressure uh and then using
Newton's Second Law we well we combine
the forces in order to get the
acceleration okay so that's the basic
model um often I show this to scientists
at least the scientists they're willing
to listen uh this is way too much they
don't like the Cycles it's really kind
of scary so just if it makes you happy
you can also unfold this in time BAS
basically treat all the variables
connected by ordinary causal arrows as
simultaneous and the integration link
says giving you cross time step
um causal relationships and you can
unpack it in this way and one thing you
notice is that even though there's a
cycle in the dynamic graph it's not
technically
cyclic uh and yeah so if this graph
helps you understand things better great
uh notice that we're still not using
time ordering to Sol caal ordering uh
the really crucial information contained
in this graph isn't that you know we're
looking at what precedes what and using
that to solve for the time ordering what
really matters is that we have these
clusters of variables influencing one
another at different rates such that
clusters of variables that are very
tightly connected and influence one
another quickly at a time scale those
are influences simultaneous and
influences that take that are treated as
taking time over that time scale are Tre
treated
dionic so this type of representation is
capturing time scale separation facts as
opposed to using the time order to solve
for the causal
ordering uh now most importantly for us
today is when you use the compact not
roll out representation you can apply an
operation known as
equilibration and equilibration is when
you take a variable in a dynamic graph
that has not reached equilibrium and you
apply equilibration to determine what
the equilibrium graph will
be okay so this works as follows so
first you set all derivatives of volume
to zero remove them from the model you
also delete all equations going into um
volume and remove their derivatives uh
this includes the integration
equations and then you remap using the
causal ordering and perhaps
unsurprisingly when you do that you end
up with well one of our initial causal
models uh namely the one in which
pressure and temperature cause
volume uh I'll say a bit more about that
but again the the important thing here
is that equilibration takes a model in
which you had a feedback loop uh and you
derive the model that would result from
equilibrating that feedback loop so
allowing the system to run to
equilibrium as a result of
self-regulation okay much more familiar
is the notion of
intervention uh so that's just the do
operator
and sorry okay away the punch line and
the only sort of surprise here is that
when you intervene on a variable with
derivatives in the model you also
intervene on its higher order
derivatives so the thought is something
like you can't you know intervene on the
position of an object with Al without
also setting its velocity and
acceleration to zero okay so when we do
that we get a different
model and in this particular case we saw
that with the dynamic model I gave you
uh if you intervene you get one model uh
the one corresponding to the fixed
volume system if you equilibrate you get
a different model the one corresponding
to the movable piston uh and without
going too much into the details the fact
you get these two models has actually
been a source of lots of consternation
uh so Denver Dash in his
dissertation uh he thought that this is
really a problem with equilibrium models
uh for reasons that I'm not going to
really go deeply into uh what I want to
argue is that actually it's the right
result the we get these two different
equilibrium models uh and the reason is
that basically what equilibration is
telling you is what happens if you allow
the system to reach equilibrium via a
via a feedback loop that you know allows
it to
self-regulate uh now when you in
contrast intervene on volume you're not
allowing that feedback loop to operate
uh and as some of you probably know
feedback loops are necessary to obtain
certain types of stability
so when you intervene on the system and
when you intervene not just temporarily
but hold volume fixed you're not
allowing the feedback loop to operate
you're destroying the stability um
producing property of the system and
you're bringing it to a different stable
State uh the one corresponding to the
fixed volume container so I think what's
going on here is that we just have these
two systems that with two relations and
the interesting result is that
intervening and equilibrating just bring
the system into two different
incompatible States
okay so that was the main technical
parts now we can uh sum up you how this
relates to time scale uh so first of all
so we saw equilibration which once again
it takes a feedback loop that in one
model reflects a variable that has not
reached equilibrium and involves
treating the reaction time as if it were
instantaneous uh now there's another
operation which I'm going to describe
called Exogen isation which involves
treating a variable that's changing
extremely slowly as if it were
constant and using the time scale
picture we could think about these
operations in terms of zooming out and
zooming in so equilibration is when we
zoom out to a time scale at which
something that at the previous time
scale was taking time to occur but we
zoom out and we can treat it as
instantaneous uh while Exogen iation is
be OB as changing at a time scale and we
zoom into a time scale at which the rate
of change is so slow that we could treat
it as
constant uh now going back to our
original example uh we can Now
understand it in terms of exonization so
once again we had this case where we had
one model without a cycle uh and where
vinall was exogenous another one with a
cycle and it's a very simple example but
the punch line is that Exogen isation is
the operation that allows one to treat
rainfall as exogenous and the big
takeaway of that for time scale is that
it wasaki and Simon's Dynamic causal
models provide a framework for capturing
this time scale relativity of causal
relationships uh so these operations
allow us to understand the relationships
between causal models at different time
scales in a systematic
way and one thing to note is that the
relationships can really look very
different at the different time
scales okay now the rest of the talk I'm
going to quickly do some implications
because really what I want to do in this
talk I mean again I'm happy to talk
about the technical details with anyone
who wants to get into them
but I really think that this whole
framework and this whole way of thinking
both in terms of time scale and
stability it introduces lots of things
into the philosophical and scientific
study of causation that at least as far
as I could tell other people aren't
talking about and I really just want to
convince you all that you should
actually think about it as well okay so
here are some implications uh this one
first one is
philosophical so as cartright told all
of us uh no causes in no causes out um I
I agree with cartright on
this and that means for example you
can't define something like exogeneity
without causal assumptions uh and I
again totally agree with that but I
think people use that as a way to end
the conversation and say like okay well
then there's just nothing we can say you
just you know you say how do I know this
variable is exogenous and they say like
look at your scientific theory or
something and you go well thanks so much
I no idea and and I think that we can
say more about I think seeing how
assumptions such as exogeneity vary with
the time scale which we consider system
does tell us something about how the
world is and needs to be in order for us
to make these assumptions uh so we can
see for example that you know in this
simple crop example that uh well we're
saying it's exogenous and we can allow
that the world's more complicated but if
we genuinely think the influence is
minor and slow acting that would be a
legitimizing assumption for treating it
as exogenous at the time
scale uh additionally I think this does
have some payoff for some philosophical
debates including uh engaging with
people like Janan uh so this uh the
previous talk sets this up nicely um so
one thing uh Janan writes about in how
causes depend on us is building on the
pean picture she referred to uh there's
this idea that causal relationships are
relative to the choice of exogenous and
endogenous variables uh and she has her
own story about how this Choice does
depend on features of agency and I'm not
going to really uh risk saying anything
too ambitious in this short talk but I'm
I'm just making the claim that having a
more well having a general theory a
theory of the type I'm providing of what
it is in the world that allows you to
think systematically about exogeneity
will also allow us to continue that
discussion uh and similarly for
discussions that have come up in several
of the talks about is there causation in
closed deterministic systems where you
sort of reach a standoff because again
going back to janon talk uh we
understand in open systems what the
exogenous factors are but let's just
kind of generalize out and think about
the universe as a whole and we can
Define exogenous or of variation we
don't know what they refer to in the
world uh and again I just think having
more resources to not just stipulate
that certain things are exogenous but
also think about it in we understand
what are the features of the world that
allow us to treat it like such seems to
me like a way to advance this
discussion um something else uh this is
more on the modeling side uh so there's
lots of debates about causation in
complex
systems uh and here I'm just going to
quickly illustrate uh again without
giving the details of
how um we can use these types of models
to really think about some standard
complex systems uh so one that gets
talked about a lot um especially in
cognitive science is the watt Governor
uh so this is a device for regulating
the speed of steam engines uh the idea
was is that people were using steam
engines to do work uh say hooking them
up to uh a loom for weaving uh you want
them to do regular work but the work
sources are not constant there could be
changes in the workload changes in the
you know coal uh so this was a device
that instead of having to have some
human there as you might think who would
see the Chang in the workload respond to
them uh this is a control feedback loop
where what happens is you have these fly
balls uh which are have a mass uh that
are connected to a spindle and if for
example oh and then the spindle is
rotating uh proportional to the speed of
the steam engine if for example the
steam engine starts to speed up above
the desired value the fly balls start to
to go out due to the uh centrifugal
force and then the spindles are hooked
up to the um throttle valve in a way
that as the fly balls go up uh the valve
is slightly shut so you get a negative
feedback loop increases in speed above
the desired value cause the system to
automatically slow down uh let less
steam into the engine and vice
versa uh so this is again widely
discussed in cognitive science
especially it's also just a kind of
Paradigm example in at least
mathematical discussions of um dynamical
systems and control systems uh in
reality people don't use this design so
much anymore but that's a you know but
it's a it's a nice mathematical model so
uh if you're ever in Munich you can also
see lots of them at the deutches
Museum so uh in Van gelder's seminal
discussion of this uh as a sort of model
of Dynam dynamical cognition he makes
the claim that when we understand the
behavior the Watts Governor the system's
entire operation is smooth and
continuous there's no possibility of
non-arbitrarily dividing its changes
over time into distinct manipulations
and no point in trying to do
so uh so here he's giving an argument
against H why what this system is doing
shouldn't be understood using a
computational
model um that's obviously not what what
we're talking about today but I think
this type of argument or this type of
perception of complex dynamical systems
as being such that every part influences
every other part at the same rate
irreducibly also is the type of argument
you see people giving against causal
interpretations of dynamical
systems uh and therefore it's somewhat
significant that when you actually try
to model the system uh dynamically and
causally you see that in fact uh it is
not such that you can't decompose it uh
and in fact uh you can give a causal
model of this sort I've been giving so
basically and without getting into the
details uh you have this causal model
showing how Theta the angle of the arms
depends on gravity length and speed of
the engine uh and how the angle of the
arms determines the steam led into the
engine uh p is the workload and those
determine the change in speed uh so this
is just an example of how to use these
types of models to model a slightly more
complicated dynamical system system
and hopefully give you some some
confidence that we can generalize this
because these types of feedback loops
are not rare so so this system is still
relatively simple but the use of control
feedback loops is not uh and here we see
that you are able to model it causally
um and as with the previous uh part of
the talk I'm not make going to make some
huge sweeping Claim about you what this
tell us about causation and dynamical
systems I'll just say that this is the
type of example lots of philosophers are
talking about and people are making
claims about causation and complexity
and as far as I know no one has actually
tried to causely model it and show this
could be done uh so as with other parts
of the T I think there's a lot of
opportunity here to take a lot of what
philosophers are doing uh informally and
to think of it more rigorously and and
I'll just say that through the process
of building this model I learned a lot
about the system that I had not gotten
from the philosophical treatments uh so
um I do think it's Illuminating
okay now in the last implication I'm
going to talk about stability uh because
once again uh a feature of these models
is that looking at the feedback loops in
the dynamic model can allow us to see
the stability uring mechanisms uh
underlying some more stable Behavior Uh
and I think stability is one of those
things that really has not been talked
about enough at least not in this way in
the context of causation uh and I think
this is going to be a payoff that also
has lotss of practical implications so
for one
thing lots of interv interventions we
care about they're not just trying to
change the value of a single variable
but really trying to get a system to be
in a new stable State uh so one example
of this at least if I'm understanding it
I would be chemotherapy so not knowing
the underlying science but I take it
what you're trying to do is you start
with a case where the body is where the
immune system is not such that it is
able to eradicate the cancer and you
want to apply chemotherapy to weaken the
cancer to the point that then the immune
system can take over so what you're
trying to do is change the Dynamics of
the system so that once you remove the
therapy it will be it will have a
different stable State and one that is
hopefully more favorable to the patient
uh I also put in therapy therapy here at
least some types of talk therapy are
also trying to change your patterns of
behavior so that you end up in a
different stable State as opposed to the
ones that make you more miserable
so I think to just characterize what the
goals are of many interventions we do
need to talk about stability uh and that
many policies shouldn't be considered
successful unless they actually produce
stable Solutions and not just bring
about an effect uh and I think a
discussion where this would really help
is the discussion of causal
extrapolation so this is the question of
how
to infer causal relations across
populations uh you find out that a
certain Ed tion policy worked in one
place will it work in another uh very
often it doesn't
um and many people including Nancy car
and Jeremy Hardy have talked about these
types of
inferences and the type of treatment
they and again is not just them everyone
pretty much gives are fairly static
representations so they talk about
background factors here they have in
mind macky's Inus conditions where the
idea is well you have these different
populations if it's a say a teaching
context May one population has a better
supply of teachers uh the second
population does not so that's why the
cause didn't generalize across the
populations because one of them had the
necessary background factors uh while
the second one did
not and what I want to suggest is that
even when we're considering single
population so before you get to
extrapolation does this cause
generalize um we shouldn't just think
about some static set of factors if
you're designing an educ
policy and you're hoping that the kids
will do the homework uh that would be
helpful for the policy but it should be
the case that if you discover that in a
particular area kids are not doing the
homework uh that there should be some
mechanism that detects that this is
happening and implements a feedback loop
to shift the policy to correct for that
deficiency so to think about a policy
succeeding we want not just to happen to
succeed but also to be dynamically
stable in light of possible
perturbations uh and I think if we
started modeling that which I think
requires Dynamic models uh that would
also help understanding how we are not
just lucky when we get generalizability
okay so just to conclude uh so first of
all I've argued that many basic
assumptions of clal models are time
scale relative uh I think time scale
relativity is hugely important uh and
presents both philosophical
opportunities for understanding the
conditions of attribution of causal
models uh and for also doing better
causal inference and policy evaluation
uh and also uh that the notion of
dynamical stability is different than
the Notions of stability that exist in
literature because most of the existing
discussions are implicitly considering
static models uh so thank you very
[Applause]
much hi thanks for for the great talk um
so so when you do these model
transformation ations going from a lower
level causal model through I think you
call it exageration and uh I forget the
other one um any calibration yeah
um is there a change in the kinds of
questions that you can ask the kind of
inference queries you can pose against
the the the abstracted model and is
there a change in the accuracy of of the
inferences right if you're making this
assumptions about you know this this spe
and steady state it seems like uh there
might be some and accuracy and so is
there is there a precise way in which
you can know what that will be yeah
that's that that's a great question um
and the answer is ultimately yes there
can be a loss and accuracy but I'll have
to be precise about what that is so I do
think and it's been important for me to
argue that the models are correct in the
domains of or at the scales of interest
and to at least so in my intervening and
letting go paper I uh explain you
because you actually do need to revise
some adequacy conditions and causal
models but I at least I've argued that
could be done um but there is a loss and
the loss is basically that if you have a
system that intervening on certain
variables will destabilize it uh you're
not always going to be able to see that
at the you know larger time scale uh
there just so the dynamic model will
kind of you'll see the feedback loop
you'll know the result of intervening uh
while other models you know because
you're just not zooming in enough uh you
won't be able to see that so that that
is a loss
and yeah and I and I think it's it's an
argument for you know doing more work on
Dynamic modeling and exploring it but
again I part of why I do want to argue
is even if that's helpful to do we can
still understand models in the own terms
because at the end of the day I think
we're always at a time scale so we're
never going to get to the bottom level
so we better have a story about why you
know why at least we can understand
models as you as being potentially
legitimated at different time scales
even if like any model they might break
down
sometimes thanks so much um so there was
something that uh a lot of what you said
just resonates with thinking about
practice in physics where you want to
understand stability under perturbations
for any system you're looking at and you
want to try to uh look at different time
scales to see if there's you know things
that you have to take into account if
you're really trying to extrapolate over
uh you know large scales and I was
curious how the how you'd characterize
the contrast between the the way that
dynamical causal modeling approaches
those that distinguishes it from just
the sort of standard techniques if you
just had a partial differential equation
and you're looking at stability and
perturbation analysis awesome thanks so
much for your question and uh and one
thing just to say so I think the one
person I've seen and maybe there's a
bunch but the one I've come across who I
think really does get the stability
right in the context of physics is Yim
uh in her causality and physics book uh
and she also has some interesting things
to say about stability and historical
explanation so I'll throw that out there
um in some ways they might not be all
that different or at least at least
here's one thing that can happen when
you when you find yourself modeling
something like the governor and so so
something like equilibration it's it's
not radically different than what you do
when you have a set at differential
equations and you you know solve by
sending something to zero um
and in that sense uh on the positive
side it creates a continuity between
differential equation practice and
causal modeling on the other hand you
might be inclined to say like look
everything you were doing I could have
just done with the differential
equations um and it's a discussion we
you know need to have whether that's in
fact true I mean for me the continuity
is a good
thing
and I guess I say at least this because
it's a longer discussion which is so
first of all I I don't think that my
discussion says anything General about
whether Dynamic systems in general can
be modeled what I've shown at best is
that when you have dynamical systems
that can be written in a certain
canonical form uh they can also be
interpreted causally now whether that's
in some cases that might not contribute
that much to the modeling practice but
philosophically I do think it's
important because you see so many claims
about um you know again not being able
to have causation and dynamical systems
and here we see that the analysis is uh
similar now in terms of what we learn I
think I think it creates a bridge where
you can argue either way you can argue
that fundamentally the uh assumptions in
the differential equations model they
thought of were non-causal assumptions
are causal assumptions uh or you can go
in the other way and say look you know
the causal is just a unhelpful
abstraction from the differential
equations so you probably know which way
I want to go but uh but yeah that's a
longer discussion so Chris we have a uh
benan was part of a discussion so the
video is available on the website if you
go so I have a very quick question
before the next speaker um comes up to
set up and that is we can treat these
exogenous factors right so in the
rainfall wheat example that you showed
uh because they operate on completely
different time scales right so the sort
of a decoupling of time scales but
underlying that isn't there an addition
assumption as well that the variations
on that other time scale that imposes on
the system are really
small right when we are studying on the
time scales that we have chosen to study
the variations on not only is the time
scale longer but the variations that it
can produce in the system are very small
over the interval of study because we're
choosing to focus on a particular time
scale right that's right yeah okay yeah
so that's an additional assumption that
it doesn't have okay yeah great um thank
you so much let's uh move on to our next
speaker